et pour terminer ce journal c'est côté
cuisine que nous allons faire un tour et
qu'elle cuisine du côté de joël robuchon
qui a été sacré aujourd'hui grand chef
de l'année
[Musique]
je marche de couverts de tares de rweb
de vos menus légère
oui chef joël robuchon le maître
aujourd'hui à d'abord appris à le dire
depuis l'âge de 15 ans car depuis ses
débuts au relais de poitiers il a tout
fait gravi tous les échelons
mais à 28 ans il commandait déjà les 90
cuisinier d'un grand hôtel parisien
ce chef
aujourd'hui consacré est célèbre pour
ses créations par exemple sont rouges et
aux épices à l'émulsion d'huile d'olive
et encore sages les deux caviars à la
crème d'aspect rj
mais il demande à être jugé plutôt sur
ce mayonnaise et sa purée pommes de
terre en purée de pomme était à tout le
monde moi je la perdrai pas me taire
tout le monde connaît les terres et
chacun en souvenir la durée de sa mère
de sa grand-mère de son enfance
lorsqu'on arrive 20 cuisiniers pour une
somme de 45 clients travaillent dans ce
temple de la gastronomie
évidemment le menu dégustation n'est pas
donné 690 feront sans les boissons pour
faire de la bonne cuisine il faut le
meilleur produit donc on recherche
meilleur produit possible par exemple je
fais venir le poisson par exemple
directement de bretagne bombe à cette
impasse on ce sont des poissons de
petits bateaux passons de ligne donc il
encore plus cher ta boisson qui est
pêché le soir que j'ai le lendemain
matin faut payer le transport pour des
petites quantités donc ça fait déjà
défrayé fait le vaux bien d'aurillac par
exemple bon vin comme envoie un petit
morceau de vaud d'aurillac
bref chez robuchon pas d'une assiette
n'est servi sans être passés entre les
mains du chef
[Musique]